[Musique]
j'y vais ou j'y vais pas en amour ce
n'est pas toujours évident de se lancer
et les premiers pas sont souvent les
plus délicats mais alors qui doit les
faire ses premiers pas et garçons aiment
bien que les filles viennent faire le
premier pas et vice versa mais je pense
que depuis longtemps ça a été l'homme
qui le garçon qui va faire le premier
pas et qui va draguer un bon jour à
cesser la tradition passe toujours les
mêmes qui ont été vos premiers pas que
je trouve c'est beaucoup plus sympa
c'est plus romantique et c'est mieux
qu'il fasse le premier pas parce
qu'enfin on arrive à faire
j'aimerais mieux que ça soit les six
qu'il fasse le premier pas presque moi
je suis un peu timide alors j'ai un peu
peur d'avancer
sipa les filles sont plus timides que
les garçons me prendre une veste
oui ça m'est déjà arrivé
[Musique]
cobra
et si les rôles s'inversaient et que ce
soit les filles qu'ils fassent les
premiers pas si j'aimerais bien qu'un
jour une fille fasse le premier pas pour
savoir ce que ça donne moi j'aime pas
trop pas les premiers pas parce que bon
c'est jamais agréable quand on dit non
mais en général j'y vais quand je suis
quasiment sûr que la personne va
répondre oui j'ai pas encore essayé je
perds le faire bientôt
ça m'est déjà arrivé de passer d à côté
d'une histoire d'amour parce que ni l'un
ni l'autre n'avait osé le faire le
premier pas et
on a vraiment regretter c'est dommage de
se borner et dire non il faut pas y
aller parce que ce garçon qui doit pas
les premiers pas le premier jeu si on
aime vraiment quelqu'un on peut très
bien y aller même si on n'aime pas
spécialement mais je crois que c'est pas
c'était peut-être un largueur apprend
qu'il ya 20 ans mais actuellement je
crois que il ya beaucoup de filles qui
sont très entreprenante de même qu'il ya
beaucoup de garçons qui gêne pas et il
n'y a pas de raison de faire des
catégories de dire moi j'irais pas moi
non plus c'est dommage quoi alors c'est
compris quand faut y aller fini la
débandade et autant y aller à 2
[Musique]